not only are we in the middle of a
pandemic but there's also like a really
beautiful movement happening right now
with black lives matter and you've been
very vocal about that on your social
media you've posted a picture of Matt
and atlas together saying you know it
starts and it stops in the home as Atlas
grows up what kind of conversations will
you have with her I mean even right now
to be quite honest we're reading books
one of her nighttime books is is for
activists you know we're starting her
right now because I think it's so
important to educate them at a young age
to that thinking about that you know
truly no matter what you look like
like who deserves to love and you love
without judgment we all and end all like
that's it and the special girl coming
from you want mixed family herself I
just I hope that it's in our generation
and I really pray that it's for hers as
well that there will be a huge change
and I slowly see it right now first when
asked about this new initiative with
safeguards what exactly is it and why
did we want to get involved yes so this
was a really exciting and important
initiative that I wanted to get involved
with safeguard is donating 10 million
dollars worth of product and hygiene
education to underserved communities
through organizations like Save the
Children which you know is incredibly
important especially in today's climate
you know as community slowly start to
open up kids are gonna be going back to
school and playgrounds and you just want
to teach them the importance of washing
their hands and maintaining a healthy
your little one isn't even quite 1 years
old yet nope how will you make
hand-washing and hygiene fun for her and
she starts to get older and I mean even
kind of right now yeah absolutely I mean
we started already you know it's part of
her nighttime routine she's touching
everything and everything in our mouth
so you want to start them as early as
possible and it's you know part of the
time when she goes to bed we're like
okay watch your hands
I sing happy birthday twice over I may
or may not
do a little dance it's a full routine
but she's certainly laughing the whole
time and you know it's definitely gonna
be something she looks back on hopefully
with fond memories I'm sure that you
never thought that the majority of your
first year of motherhood would be spent
like this I mean what has the experience
been like for you have there been
challenges has it been more fun because
you are with with her constantly yeah
it's been a little bit of both I mean
every single day with her has been so
wonderful considering that you know that
wouldn't have been the case before Matt
and I both travel so often that you know
being able to spend this much time as a
family together at with her at such an
early age is incredible however there
are obviously challenges because I wish
my mom and my dad could be here Matt's
family you know my grandma obviously I
want to have time with a plan so as soon
as you know things hopefully open up and
it's safe I can't wait to go to
Vancouver and bring her over there what
would your message to other parents be
who are raising kids right now in this
pandemic yeah I would say I mean we'd by
example right now I always you know our
kids are always not mimicking us and
doing it especially Atlus at eight
months old
you know I stick my tongue out she is
she does everything that I'm doing so I
think Justin's setting an example and
starting these healthy habits as early
as possible so you know with her seeing
that I'm doing it she'll hopefully do it
so that when the world opens back up and
they go out we can know that they are
continuing to do so
tick tock you're killin it on there
thank you I'm very impressed
hey how did you learn to get so creative
with the app because it takes a minute
to like kind of figure it out and be
there is a tick tock challenge listed
yes get to that tuba first I'm talking
you're tick-tock figure then okay so I
mean I honestly felt like a grandma
getting back on that because Elliott
wait a minute this is a new platform I
want to do it you know I had to call on
my little cousin yeah so yeah it was
something that was obviously so
challenging at the beginning to get to
get a hold of but it's fun and it's like
a workout trying to memorize these
dances it's so difficult it takes me a
good hour to and I'm sweating by the end
of it but then you know hopefully
something happens it's good so that's
why you know when when safeguard was
like hey we're gonna do this challenge
I'm like what a better way than to
obviously do something fun
make it a trend like have other people
really learn the importance of the
proper way to wash your hands and dance
while doing it do you just have a
message of help right now to your fans
yeah I don't want to just say you know
take a day by day and and and you know
let's do what we can to keep ourselves
not only ourselves but our family our
friends in our community safe you know
maintaining a healthy lifestyle teach
your kids and your friends wouldn't say
washing your hands cuz it can go such a
long way and safeguarding your family
and everybody around you
[Music]